oh my gosh the pieces of
fire is this okay yeah it's okay
hey it's nicole russell from last dragon
pizza and welcome to pizza wars on first
sweet peas
for some people pizza is all about
tradition dough sauce
cheese and that's it but today we're
boldly going where
no pizza chef has gone before i'm
talking about the crazy
over-the-top show-stopping slices you
see going viral online and i can't think
of anyone better for a viral piece of
showdown
than mike's tony below
[Music]
what's up everyone my name is mike
founder and owner of tony baloney's
straight from jersey so we're making
some crazy [ __ ] today
we got a cowboy style pizza called the
flaming cowboy
i get [ __ ] all day long from the
traditional pizza makers
oh you're putting things on pizza tacos
how gimmicky is that
until they try it and let go my
grandfather's rolling in his grave
but too bad i know mike is going to do
something crazy today but you know
i want to take this in another direction
i'm going to be making a tavern style
bar pot
with a crust made from popcorn
my friends mark iacono and scott weiner
are the judges today
these guys really know their pizza and
they aren't impressed by all the stunt
slices out there
so i think they're really gonna like my
dish nicole is no
joke but i'm prepared to slaughter at
all cost
i need that golden piece of trophy tony
baloney
you're going down
[Music]
okay mike i'm so happy you're here when
i heard it was you
i said oh my gosh what is he gonna do
so go ahead what you doing mine first of
all it is game ah it's game on i am so
excited to be here with you
i know you probably got some crazy stuff
up your sleeve but today
it's all about ribs in the pizza with
the bone
the whole nine yards so i'm gonna go
home and let my i'm just gonna
go ahead mike so we're gonna do first
and foremost extra virgin olive oil get
a little in the pan
schmutz it around with your hands and
then i got this dough
so this is 72 hours fermented put in the
pan
okay i'm going to press it out just like
that this is serious
we're not [ __ ] around all right the
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to grill up our onions
okay now this is the flaming cowboy so
there's a cowboy chilling out
right with the hanging his mouth he's
got some chaps on
are they assless or not i don't know
right come up with this stuff
and what is he doing he's chewing on
some hay all right
and then maybe what he's doing he's
maybe smoking the hay smoke in the head
so with saute this some smoked some
grass
now the next thing we got is this short
rib we took a whole wrap we then put
them in a braise
in the oven for eight hours wow that's a
long this [ __ ]
cooked and the best part is the bone
started getting dislodged and then i
cubed it up put it back in the liquid
cooked it for another hour
so after an hour this is what you get oh
my gosh
that's where it's at right there and
we're gonna put it all with the pizza
this is looking fantastic all right hold
on
let me see you squeeze the juice out the
meat yeah why not when you start
squeezing the juice out the meat that's
insane
all right so the short-lived meat is
down
on the pizza then what we're gonna do is
continue to saute this up
right get everything real [ __ ] messy
yeah
now it's time to dress this up with the
bones oh
so for this we're gonna set the bones
down on the pizza
what just like this what one t-rex is
going
and three we get some cheese on this we
got skamore to cheese and then blended
it with
dry aged low moisture mozzarella all
right now
we're gonna take this dough and we're
gonna layer it over wow put it down
once i connect them i want that detroit
style edge
so what i'm going to do is take a little
more cheese and then i'm going to tuck
them in between the dough
and the pan and that cheese as you know
is going to caramelize
i'm just going to stick around for my
challenge but
uh i'm just gonna stick around because
this is insane right in the oven
rock 450 done oh that looks crazy
oh yeah look at that oh
m g mike what's that in your hand this
is the cowboy juice
cowboy juice put that all over this
pizza just like that
what's going on right he just went in
what in the
did you just set the pizza on fire set
it on fire you know what and then we
made
smoked strachatella which is basically
brotha filling and we're gonna put this
cowboy fire out
you're putting out a fire on a pizza
with cheese oh my goodness just like
that
i am in awe look at how that pops out ah
get along little doggy that's insane
you want to do the honors okay you have
the bone all right a little bit
wiggle it a little bit pull it out
and the bone is hot let's
cut it like this wow
cheers cheers what do cowboys say they
don't say cheers
[Music]
craziness right here and the meat is
just dropping out
hot diggity [ __ ] dog that [ __ ]
is good
mike this exceeded anything i could ever
imagine
you brought your a game today i mean my
goodness
i think my pizza is in the complete
opposite direction
of this i want to taste your pizza okay
let's go
okay let's go competition let's do it
let's go let's go
all right but wait
[Music]
okay mike the flaming cowboy blew my
mind
but let me tell you what i was thinking
as far as viral is concerned okay
people are always calling me oh nicole
do you have keto pizza
nicole do you have gluten-free pizza
so i thought i would make a bar pizza
out of popcorn oh that's my favorite
snack
you like popcorn i love popcorn you're
gonna make popcorn right now yes
i mean maybe this would be a great money
making pizza too
yeah i hope so because the cauliflower
one
went crazy yeah and you saw her oprah
dad didn't even call me
oprah oh cauliflower pizza oprah that's
my stuff you know me but when she sees
my popcorn pizza yeah she's like oh
yeah and i'm gonna be like you're too
late sorry oprah as a matter of fact
you're the flaming cowboy
yeah this is the better than oprah oh i
like that
popcorn crust i like that pizza
all right look at that fresh popcorn
is that now that that's pops we need to
bind it together so i'm gonna use some
egg
a little cheese a little rosemary for
flavor
and i'm gonna take the popcorn and dump
it right in
i've never seen this before i'm gonna
pour it out here
and push it out to the edge and make it
nice and round
i'll put money on it oprah's [ __ ]
her pants right now watching this all
right we're gonna slide this directly in
the oven
set to 550 for like four to six minutes
there we go wow look at that thing and
now you can top this with anything you
can make a margarita
plain cheese pepperoni but i'm gonna
stick with my bar
pizza theme and i'm gonna go with a clam
love crab beauty so i got my whole milk
mozzarella now
i'm gonna put some on there so these are
freshly chopped
raw clams and we're just gonna put them
on our pie
and i made a little clam sauce
all right that looks legit you think so
it's a straight stunner
yes all right so what we're gonna do is
put it right back in the oven and we're
gonna bake this for another
four or five minutes yo look at this
thing this is like show-stopping
picture-worthy
okay i think it's done let's go and see
it oh
look at that okay mike
there it is this is my version of a
bar pie made of popcorn and it's better
than oprah's
it's got the crust on it it's holding up
you can actually hold a slice
yeah look at that hold on
you like it oprah you're going down i'm
trying to tell you oprah
i'm trying to tell you this is that good
yeah i'm telling you
really really good okay well your pizza
was literally fire
and my pizza popped so now we're gonna
take both of our pies
to the judges table so we have mark
iacona here from lucalis
legendary and then we also have scott
from scott pizza tours and you know
scott
and mark together have eaten a lot of
crazy pizza including yours
on really though so let's see what they
think of our creations today let's do it
let's go
mark scott thank you so much for being
here
we're so excited to have you mike you go
first tell them what you got i'm ready
this is called
the flaming cowboy so fellas grab on to
your assless chaps
and let's eat some [ __ ] pizza you
ready
give me a yeehaw what is that oh my god
very nervous
let's go scott set it on fire oh my gosh
the pieces are fire is this okay
yeah it's okay wait you call that a
pizza
[Music]
mark be my first guest please pull the
bone
any bone any bone i don't know it's like
attached to this not that one
wow bring this home to my dog
this looks insane but we have to eat it
because that's the show ready
yeah of course i'm ready
[Music]
that meat on the inside tastes awesome
and it being kind of in the innards of
this pizza situation
i'm surprised at how well it works i
thought it was just going to be a
mishmash of nightmares
but it's awesome very cheesy i think
you're being way too kind
to mike it is a miss mosh no i'm only
kidding mike
i like it yeah he's eating it i'm eating
it i think you could have like maybe
chop the scallions a little smaller
because it's like i'm pulling out like
hole like that just coming out but other
than that this is fantastic
is this a pizza no this is a short red
pot pie
for once we've got a teller on top no
way i agree but it's delicious
so what you guys have in front of you is
my version of a bar
pie but the crust is made from popcorn
gluten-free keto friendly and a little
seafood
so there you go oh ready sky
it folds look at the underside beautiful
like you're taking notes i'm [ __ ]
taking it
yeah 100
oh my god do you like it first of all
this
acts like a pizza which i didn't expect
because it's this popcorn based crust
but it has the greatest thing that
happened to pizza of all time which is
burnt cheese and the whole bottom of
this
is that caramelized cheese and then on
top of that fresh clam
and the citrus it's that counterpoint to
the burnt cheese
it cuts through the fattiness of it it's
awesome it's kind of crazy how
mike made a detroit style pizza and
nicole made
a corn clam pizza her tastes more
detroit
than mike's does i guess that's the
caramelized cheese on the bottom
oh um i think it would have been really
nice if you drew some uh chopped
calabrian chilies on top of this
yeah i wasn't sure but yeah that's
probably a good suggestion
but other than that i love the texture
the everything about it is fantastic
okay mark and scott taking everything
into consideration
creativity how good it tastes which one
you think will go more viral what do you
guys think
[Music]
as much as mike's is throwing the
kitchen sink
on a pizza in a totally insane
disorganized disheveled nightmarish
confusing upsetting
disturbing way i think that this is the
one
that more people will get jazzy about so
i think it's the
flaming cowboy creativity and taste i'm
gonna go with the clam pie but as far as
viral goes
flaming cowboy but i want to eat this
more
mike it's been a pleasure having you on
this was super tough you pulled a bone
out of a pizza i mean i gotta lose to
that and you set it on fire
so the trophy is yours thank you so much
thank you listen i loved your pizza
thank you i could eat that
all day every day this is
the crowning achievement of my entire
life i don't doubt that don't tell my
wife and kids
so guys this was super fun thank you
guys so much for coming on
and we'll see you next time on peace
[Music]
awards
you